CHET HAASE: Good afternoon and
welcome to Material Witness.
We thought it would be good
to write some actual code,
using some of the new
Material Design APIs
and talk about how
we did it, and also
more interestingly,
how some of the stuff
works under the covers.
ROMAIN GUY: Yeah, so just
one little caveat-- Chet just
mentioned writing code.
And since we're
both managers now,
we don't really write
code anymore for a living.
So forgive us if
the code is weird.
CHET HAASE: We should have
people to write this for us.
So I don't know if
you know who we are.
I'm Chet Haase.
I'm on the Android
UI Toolkit team.
I don't know who this is.
ROMAIN GUY: I'm Romain Guy.
I used to be on the
Android UI Toolkit team,
until-- [CHEERING] Thank you.
--until Chet decided
he wanted my job.
And so now I'm
working on robots.
CHET HAASE: Are they
clapping because you
used to be on the team?
ROMAIN GUY: I think so.
CHET HAASE: Or
because you're gone?
ROMAIN GUY: Gee,
he's finally gone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHET HAASE: Moving on-- oh,
those awkward protesters.
All right, let's take a
look at a couple of demos.
So I had an idea for
a demo application
we were going to do together.
It was going to
go out to Flickr.
It was going to fetch
these images, by Romain.
We'd get these beautiful images
downloading in the background.
And then we'd install
them in wallpaper,
and it would be all lovely.
And Romain is like, I
don't have time to do all.
How about if we
just hack some demos
to show the pieces that
we actually care about?
So that's what we did.
ROMAIN GUY: So we
have two demos.
We will pretend that
we have two demos,
to keep each demo simple, so
that the code will be easier
to understand, which we did
because we didn't have time
to merge the two demos.
CHET HAASE: So I have a
very simple demo showing off
some of the things we're
going to talk about today.
I tend to look at my
demos as simple things
that I can write code for that
clearly explain the simple bits
that I want to help
people understand.
And then Romain writes
something similar
and actually makes it look good,
which is really embarrassing.
So here's my simple demo.
This is showing some
of the elements we're
going to talk about, in
terms of animations and cards
and some interactivity,
as you touch these things,
some ripples.
So we can sort of see
some of this in action.
Then this stuff is going to be
demonstrated in videos as we
go, so we can look
a little bit closer.
So we see a transition.
We're sharing a hero element
between these activities.
We can change and
customize the transition
and make the
elements explode out
and move out to the top and
bottom in a staggered way
instead.
OK, so that's my simple demo.
And this is the second demo.
It's a similar
idea, with images.
So we're going to see
transitions, reveals,
with live MapView.
This has nothing to do
with my actual design.
It just looks cool.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING] And if we
have time, we'll talk about it.
If you look at the
colors of the UI,
you're going to notice that
the colors are actually
coming from the
images themselves.
So this is dynamic thinning
of the app, basically, based
on colors with different images.
And again, we're going to
look at the APIs to do this.
CHET HAASE: So if
we can switch back
to the slides-- so
first of all, let's
talk about cards, one
of the simple elements
that you saw in
both of those demos.
And the cards are
the idea-- you see it
in a lot of the mocks
from the design team,
as they're talking
about material design,
setting apart the content
into these items that are then
sitting on top of these cards,
this paper representation,
elevated a bit off the
view hierarchy plane.
So they're casting a
little bit of shadow.
There's padding around the
edges, sort of a nice way
to segregate,
separate the content
with some nice white
space in there.
So we implemented that.
In my demo, I did
it very manually.
I just have a
group to sort of do
all the little bits and
pieces that need to be done.
You can also use CardView
in the support library,
to do this a little
more automatically.
So in the case of
my demo, there's
a round-rect ShapeDrawable
that I used as a background.
And then I clipped
to that outline.
And this is one of the new
APIs and capabilities exposed
in the L Release.
So you can clip and get the
nice, rounded corner there.
This is also the shape that is
used by the shadow that is then
cast onto the View
Hierarchy plane.
So as you elevate
this view, then we
cast a shadow using the outline
that you've told us your View
has.
So we get the nice
rounded, soft shadow effect
around the edges of the cards.
ROMAIN GUY: And we're going to
talk in more details about how
elevation works,
in a few minutes.
CHET HAASE: So here's how I
happen to do it in my codes.
In general, Drawables
know what shape they are.
So if you have a
ShapeDrawable, it
knows what outline it exposes.
And it can propagate that
information to the View.
So in general, Views
should know what shadow
the shape should be drawn with,
or potentially clipped to.
Some of that stuff is not
yet enabled in the preview L
Release, so I'm doing
it more manually here.
The outlines are specified
in the coordinate system
of the views themselves.
So when the View
changes size, you
need to then update the size
of the outline appropriately.
So here, we override
on Size Changed.
We get the size of the View.
We create the Round-Rect.
We set the outline to
the shape, and then we
tell it to also clip
to that shape as well.
ROMAIN GUY: And in
particular, this trick
of creating the outline
programmatically
on the onSizeChanged
is very important,
if your background is a Bitmap.
Because given the
way shadows work,
right now, this thing
is not able to generate
shadows for Bitmap.
So if your Bitmap
contains a circle,
the system doesn't
know there's a circle.
So you have to tell
the framework that's
you want a circle
for the shadow.
CHET HAASE: A lot of
the canonical cases
are going to be solved for you.
If you have a shape,
it's going to know
what shape to draw
that shadow at.
But not necessarily
all the cases, so it's
good to know how to actually
do it programmatically as well.
And then finally, we set
a shadow on the card,
simply by boosting
it up to some value.
So we've set an elevation
value of 5 here.
And as Romain said,
we're going to talk
more about shadows
and elevation later.
So you could also
just use CardView.
I didn't happen to, frankly
because it wasn't online
when I was writing some of
the bits of the demo here.
But you can use
CardView to do this.
What I did is actually
really simple.
The advantage of using
CardView is twofold.
One is that it's
standardizes your cards
with other people that happen
to be using that element,
so things look a
little more consistent
across the platform in general.
But also, in the
CardView widget,
which is in the support
library, when you're
sitting on top of
the L Release, it's
going to do the correct thing.
It's going to give
it an elevation.
It's going to clip to the edges.
It's going to do all
the L-correct things.
When it's on a
previous release, it
generates images that
look pretty much the same.
It's a very good
and consistent look.
But it's not necessarily
using-- it's certainly not
using the same capabilities,
because we didn't have shadows
prior to this release.
But it at least
uses these elements
of the different
releases, to give you
a consistent look for your
application across releases.
And you can see here, there are
examples of CardView previous
to L and in the L release.
And they look pretty similar.
And that's a good thing.
So how it works is,
basically, if you're
running on one of these
previous releases,
it generates a PNG file
with the shadow baked in,
just as you probably
would with your assets,
if you were trying to do
something on your own.
You can use Path Clipping if
you want to actually clip shapes
to a path.
It tends to be very expensive,
so we don't recommend it
as a general solution.
If we're actually
redrawing your views that
are path clipped
all the time, you're
wasting a lot of performance
that you would probably rather
be spending on other things
in the system as well.
There are also
approaches where you
can use BitmapShader to draw
and get a similar result.
This is the effect used in,
I think, Search in KitKat.
When they did a
circular reveal, they
were using a BitmapShader
to get that effect.
Again, kind of
expensive-- you don't
want it running
full-time in the system.
But it's OK for a
transient effect.
In L, it's much simpler.
We can actually
tell it the outline
to clip to and the
outline to shadow to.
And we can set the elevation
to shadow appropriately.
I didn't want to put the
actual APIs for outlines
on here, because this is
one of the areas is probably
going to be tweaked a little
bit, in the final release of L.
There's a simple way of dealing
with outlines right now.
That simple way of
dealing with outlines
is probably going to change to a
different simple way of dealing
with outlines.
So don't get too hung
up on the details,
since it's a preview release.
But the general ideas
will be the same.
Now, let's talk about Ripples.
This is touch feedback.
One of the important
elements-- we
talked about this
in earlier talks--
was to give the user
immediate feedback
of what's going
on in the system.
So we have Touch Feedback
on all the standard widgets,
so that the user knows what they
pressed and where they pressed.
And we animate the
state change over time.
And actually, you probably went
to the earlier talk anyway.
So I'm going to blow
through some of that stuff
and get to the more interesting
bits of how the stuff actually
works.
So RippleDrawable,
it's the new class.
You can use it directly.
There's other ways that you
can opt into this behavior.
And the standard widgets
have it built in.
So you can see the
Ripple behavior here.
Is that coming
across on the screen?
I think so.
And then if you stare
at it long enough,
maybe you'll have a seizure.
And here's some of the code
to enable some of the stuff.
So from XML, you can
create this RippleDrawable.
So you can optionally set
a color for your ripple.
And it basically uses
that optional color
and reveals the content that
the ripple is actually wrapping.
So in this case,
we have a Drawable
that's simply a ColorDrawable.
And that's going to
be revealed over time,
with the Ripple that's
then wrapping that item.
Or similarly, from code, you
create the RippleDrawable
class, optionally
set a color on it.
Or the easiest way to
do is actually just
to set a
selectableItemBackground.
And that means, when the
user presses on that,
puts it in its
selected state, then
it's automatically
going to run a Ripple.
The Ripple that we saw
in the seizure slide,
in the previous slide,
uses that approach.
It says, I want my foreground
to be this RippleDrawable.
So then, as the
item is selected,
it automatically emanates
that Ripple on top of it.
ROMAIN GUY: And this is
the same exact effect
in the second demo.
We just wanted to
show it to you,
because here, the ripple
is pinkish, purple.
The color comes from the scene.
So if you use the foreground
technique that Chet just
showed you on the
previous slide,
you're automatically
going to get the Ripples
with the right color
from [INAUDIBLE].
CHET HAASE: So how
they work in general--
they wrap the content.
So you can think
of it as a wrapper
around the actual content
that you're going to reveal.
And it's going to reveal that
by emanating the Ripple out
from what we call the
Hotspot, the center
point of the interaction.
If you use
selectableItemBackground,
we automatically know
where that Hotspot is.
We know where the
user's finger pressed.
And we can emanate
from that center point.
If you're doing it
more programmatically,
you can set the Hotspot.
You can set the x,y location
in the local coordinate system
of the View.
And that's where the
Ripple will emanate from.
The other interesting detail
is about the Render threads.
This came up in
one of the sessions
yesterday, that this is a
performance optimization
that we've enabled in
this preview release
and we'll be
continuing to work on,
where the drawing system usually
consists of-- or has always
consisted of-- in the
Hardware Accelerated Model.
We create display lists on
the UI Toolkit thread it,
and then we issue or
executive the display lists,
also on the UI Toolkit thread.
And that's when we
actually talk to the GPU
and send down OpenGL commands.
What we've done is broken those
out into two separate threads,
so that we create the display
list on the UI Toolkit thread.
And then the Render thread
actually talks to the GPU.
If that's all we did,
it doesn't really
buy us anything,
because we still
have to create it
before we execute it.
But now that we've been
able to break this out
into separate spreads,
what we can do
is start sending over
animations as atomic objects
to be executed wholly
on that other thread.
And the first one of those
that were working with
is the Ripple.
So you'll notice, if
you press on a button,
it launches some activity.
What you would have seen
in previous releases is,
the Ripple would stop emanating,
as soon as you started
the new activity, because the
same Toolkit thread is being
used to inflate
the new activity,
as is being used to
animate the Ripple.
So what's happening now is,
we're sending in information
about the Ripple animation
down to the Render thread.
And that is able to continue
running while the Toolkit
thread is busy inflating
the new activity.
So that's the main thing that's
executing on the Render thread
right now.
Expect more over time,
as we're able to do this.
There's some really
tricky details
about what we can
run on either thread
and what the contract with
some of the animation APIs are.
But we'll do we can
to take advantage
of this new performance
optimization.
Now let's talk about Shadows.
I'm going on and on.
But trust me, he's going to
talk for a lot, after I'm done.
Shadows are the idea of
boosting views in 3D,
raising them above what is
essentially the Z=0 plane
of the View Hierarchy.
One important detail
here is that we're
using orthographic projection.
So typically, if we had a
full-on perspective camera
world, then as you raised things
up, they would also scale up.
Because you get
perspective foreshortening.
They would get larger, as
they came closer to the View.
That's not the projection
system that we're
using right now, due to some of
the details about how we want
the UIs to actually
interact right now.
So as Views raise up,
they are raising in Z,
and the shadows are expanding.
But they're not
actually scaling.
Sometimes, you actually
do want the effect
of scaling, in which
case you should actually
animate the scaleX and scaleY
properties of the View,
at the same time, to get that
effect that you're looking for.
We also added APIs,
not just to View,
for the properties
around Elevation,
but also to view
property animators,
so that you can easily
animate these properties.
This question came up a couple
of times in a previous session.
There's a little
bit of confusion
about what's an
Elevation and what's
TranslationZ and what Z is.
These map exactly to the
existing layout and post layout
properties for X and Y.
So if you imagine,
there's the left property,
which is the Layout
property that
says where you're going to
position this thing in X,
when Layout runs.
And then there's
TranslationX, which
is a post-layout property, which
you usually use for animations,
which is additive on top
of that left property.
And then there is an X property,
which is the sum of those.
So it's exactly the same thing
in Z. Elevation is basically
the permanent location that
you want that thing to live at.
TranslationZ is kind of a
post-layout, if you will,
property but that is then
additive on top of that.
This is going to be
used for animations.
Like if you go into a
press state and out of it,
then you would probably
animate TranslationZ,
which is going to be on top
of the Elevation parameter.
Or you can simply use Z
directly, which is additive.
It's the combination of
Elevation plus TranslationZ.
So here's a simple bit of
code that I have in my demo.
When I pressed on one of
those thumbnail images,
it raised up under my finger.
And then it went back down and
then launched the new activity,
when it was back down on
the View Hiearchy plane.
The way I did that was simply
through an easy Touch Listener.
When I pressed
down on it, I would
start an animation
that scaled in X and Y,
because I did one kind
of a perspective scaling
effect on that.
And then I would also
animate TranslationZ .
I let go, I get a
Cancel or an Up.
Then it would simply
animate back down to Z=0
or Elevation=0, or in
this case, TranslatioZ=0.
And then it would launch
the new activity from there,
fairly straightforward.
There are other
ways to accomplish
this, which we'll see
later in other code.
ROMAIN GUY: And now, I want
to talk a little bit about how
the shadows are
actually implemented.
So this is what the UI designers
wanted us to implement.
So this is an image are
rendered in Blender.
And it took 10
minutes on my laptop.
CHET HAASE: 10 minutes--
10 times 60 seconds
times 60 frames a second, yeah.
ROMAIN GUY: So not possible on
a phone, but I tried anyway.
You'll see.
So let's see what we have here.
So there's an Area Light.
And Chet mention that
in the previous session,
the Area Light is what gives
us these nice, soft shadows
that you see at the bottom.
So your Occluder is the
view, and the Area Light
will cast those
nice, soft shadows.
Now, if we implement
shadows in a naive way,
you would get something
like this, where the umbra--
So the umbra is the part of the
shadow from which you cannot
see the light at all.
So it's fully in the shadows.
And then there's the penumbra.
This is the soft edges.
So when we talk
about soft shadows,
it's just shadows that have
an umbra and a penumbra.
The problem here is, you can see
that the shadow is completely
dark.
And in real life, this
doesn't really happen,
because what
happens in real life
is that the light
bounces around.
If you lock yourself in a
room and you close the door,
after a few minutes, you'll
be able to see things.
And the reason is, light will go
through small holes in the door
and just bounce around
until it hits your eyes.
So really the effect that the
UI designer wanted was this.
And this phenomenon is
called global illumination.
So if you look here, you can
see that the shadow is not
completely dark.
It's a little hard
to see on screen.
But the color of the view
itself, the Occluder, the red,
is reflected onto the ground.
So part of the ground
is a little bit red.
And the ground itself is light.
So to implement this, just
before I left the Android team,
I wrote the first
prototype of soft shadows.
And this is what I came up with.
It was using
ray-tracing on the GPU.
It looks pretty good.
There's global
illumination approximation.
This looks fairly
similar to what
you get in Blender or any
the expensive 3-D rendering
package.
The only default, the only
issue with that approach
is that, it was running
so much code on the GPU,
that after a few
seconds, like 30 seconds,
the Nexus 4 would
overheat and reboot.
It was just trying to not melt.
CHET HAASE: So we fired him.
ROMAIN GUY: So I got
fired. [AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
So we decided that maybe this
was not the right way to do it.
So smarter people than me
found a different approach.
So basically what
happens is, the system
will calculate geometry.
It will generate a
bunch of triangles
to send to the GPU that
will represent the shadow.
And there are actually two
shadows in that system.
There's the shadow
that's generated
by the Area Light itself.
So it just projects
the Area Light
through the shape of your
View, through the outline.
And if you just did that, you'd
get that really dark shadow
that we saw before.
So the first trick is to make
that shadow semi-translucent.
So that's simulates global
illumination a little bit.
The second trick--
and it's actually
a a really nice trick-- is
to have a second shadow.
The idea is that because the
light is bouncing around,
really, the world around you
is acting as a light source.
So we're casting
a second shadows,
as if the entire world around
your device was a light source.
This is called the
Ambient Shadow.
And it's done a
little differently.
It just projects your View
straight onto the ground,
as a secondary
translucent shadow.
The effect is really subtle.
But when it's missing, it
doesn't look nearly as good.
So this is not
grounded in reality.
This is not how light
works in real life.
But as always with
graphics, what matters
is that it looks good.
How it's done doesn't
really matter.
So like I said, the
system computes geometry.
So every time you move
the View in X, Y, or Z,
so if you change the elevation,
because the light source itself
has a fixed position, the
geometry has to be recomputed.
The nice thing is, most of
the work is done by the GPU.
We just interpolate colors.
So this will show you what
the geometry looks like.
So this screenshot is taken from
another prototype that actually
runs on desktops, that
was implemented just
to play with
different algorithms.
So you have your
nice, soft shadow.
You have your view that's
tilted in 3D space.
And this is the kind of geometry
that the system will actually
generate to draw the shadow.
So here, you're seeing only one
of the two shadows I mentioned.
And the geometry
that's being used
is not necessarily
the same geometry
that's used on
the device or that
will be used on
the final release.
But this gives you an
idea of how it works.
Just one tip, when you use
those shadows-- by default,
Views have a pivot
point in the center
that's used to apply rotations.
So if you rotate your View
on the x-axis or the y-axis
and you leave the
default pivot points,
your View will intersect
with the ground.
So visually, on screen, because
it's not a real 3D system,
you won't see your view
being clipped by the ground.
There's actually no
real ground at Z=0.
But the shadow system
will think the ground
is intersecting with your View.
And you're going to get
a bunch of artifacts.
So if you want to apply
3D rotations to your View,
make sure that you set an
elevation that's high enough,
that when you rotate the
View it doesn't intersect.
It doesn't collide with
the View Hierarchy plane.
You can compute it.
It's simple trigonometry.
Or you can just play with
values until it looks good.
CHET HAASE: This is
an important point.
It's easy to misconstrue
what we've done as, hey, now
we have a full-on
3D modeling system.
No, what we've done
is used a Z value
to get physically correct
information about the View
system and shadows, as we
boost these things into Z.
But we don't have a Z buffer.
It's not a modeling system.
You can't use this as
a full-on 3D system
for doing games, where objects
can be self-intersecting,
and you actually get the
correct visual results.
It's still a fast
2D rendering system
that we've added some Z to.
But if you're doing
things like these,
you're going to run into
the edges of that system
pretty quickly.
ROMAIN GUY: Something
else that you
should be aware of-- if you
have some Views that are stacked
on top of each other
and some of these Views
are rotated in 3D space
where you use or an X or Y
rotation, the shadows that
are projected by the Views
above will not be
projected on those Views.
So the projection of
the shadow is always
meant for the ground plane.
So the shadows will
draw on top of it
the various cards in your stack.
But they won't be
applied to the Transform
planes of those different Views.
So don't hesitate to play
with the 3D Rotations.
You can create
really nice effects.
And Chet, in the previous
session today, this morning,
showed a little tilt animation,
when you drive your car.
It looks fantastic.
Just be aware of these
very small limitations.
So the shadows, so far, we've
show them mostly static.
and in Chet's demo, I
don't know if you noticed--
we're going to get back to it.
the shadows are
actually animated.
And there are various
ways of doing it.
It's very useful when you
want to create a Press
State, like an
animated Press State.
So you press on
the button, and it
feels like the button
is raising in 3D space.
And there are a couple
ways of doing that.
So you can see here.
It might be difficult
to see on screen.
But if you look at the
button on the right,
when the finger
presses the button,
you'll see the shadow
grows a little bit.
It's actually even harder
to see on your own device,
because your finger
is on top of it.
But it still looks pretty cool.
And this is how it's done.
So you can use a simple
stateListAnimator.
So the button that we
just saw in the video
is a simple Image button.
You specify a stateListAnimator.
It's a resource that lives
in the Anim directory.
And that resource
looks like this.
If you used
SelectDrawable before,
if you've created custom
drawables for buttons,
this looks very familiar.
The difference is, that inside
the Items of the selector,
instead of putting drawables,
you just put Object Animators.
So here, what we're
doing-- in the first item,
we say, when the
state is pressed,
I want you to animate
from a certain Elevation
to another Elevation.
And when, at the bottom,
the state is not pressed,
I want to animate the other way.
And that's all you have to do.
It's a very, very
easy way to create
those nice secondary
animations in your UI.
And of course, you could
inmate any property.
The only trick is,
that from XML, you
have to tell the system the type
of propert you want to animate.
You won't be able to figure
out that the TranslationZ here
is a float.
So this is how you would use the
StateListAnimators from code.
It's easier to do it from XML.
But if you want to dynamically
do those animations.
This is a better one that
you're probably familiar with.
CHET HAASE: So one of the big,
new animation capabilities
that we enabled in platform
is Activity Transitions,
in particular the
ability to share elements
between separate activities,
which before, you could do.
But it's a little tricky
to figure out how it works.
We created a DevByte
showing how you can do it.
So you can certainly take that
approach in previous releases.
But now, we've taken
the new transition
API that was new in KitKat.
And we've basically baked
that into the ability
to have much more rich
animations between activities.
So now, you can think of
these three separate phases
of these activity
transitions, where
we have an animation
that's happening
in the activity
that's going away,
where we can animate
the items out.
And we have items
in the new activity
that are going to
be animating in.
In the meantime, we're
passing information
about a shared element
between these activities.
So that we can then
animate that item
to some state in the
Launching Activity
and then animate
it from that state
into its final position
in the launched activity--
so sort of all these different
separate bits, all of which
can be customized, to
whatever extent you want.
And the information that we
pass about that shared element
is the position of that element,
the size of that element,
and a Bitmap that represents
that element, as well
as the name.
And then, if the Launched
Activity knows something
associated with that--
so if you're in music
app and you see
a list of albums.
And then you go into
a detailed view,
and you pass over a shared
element with the name Album.
Then the Launched
Activity can say, oh,
I know where to put an
album on this screen.
Sure, I'll take that element.
Then it's in control
of the transition
and can animate
it appropriately.
There's also the ability to
customize these transitions.
And that's customization in
terms of the actual transitions
you run.
So you can have different
kinds of effects.
Right here, we see two
different transitions happening.
This one is an Explode.
You can see the items animating
out to the top and the bottom.
And then we toggle
that Check Box on top.
And we get a Cross Fade, the
default Cross Fade transition
instead.
So you can customize things
with either the transitions
that we ship with the
platform or transitions
that you write on your own.
You can also
customize it, in terms
of which transitions target
which items in the UI.
So you can say, I want Fades
to happen on these targets.
I want Explodes to happen
on these other items.
And you get a much more
choreographed experience,
as you go from
activity to activity.
So here's some of
the code you would
need to use in
enabling the basics.
There's a lot more
code, a lot more APIs
that I won't go
into the details of.
First of all,
right now, you need
to be using the Material
Theme on the preview release.
That requirement may go away.
It seems like we should just
enable activity transitions
in general, if you want them.
But right now, you enable
the Material Theme.
And then you would say, I
want to use Window Content
Transitions.
You can either do this
in your theme itself.
Or you can specify this
in code, by calling
their requestFeature method.
And then you can set
some optional behaviors.
So once you enable
Transitions, you're
going to get some
default behavior.
It's just going to cross
fade between your activities,
by fading the items in and out,
as you go between activities.
But you can set up
custom animations here.
We're going to use an Explode
on the Exit Transition.
So as I leave my
activity, items are
going to stagger and animate
out to the top and the bottom.
You can also specify
the Overlap behavior.
By default, we're
going to overlap
the animations of the enter
and exit at the same time,
or as overlapped as
they can be, depending
on how long it takes the
Launched Activity to actually
inflate and get ready to go.
Or if you want to choreograph
it more carefully and say,
no, I want this animation
to finish first.
Then you can set the Overlap
property to be false instead.
And then you can
set up information
about shared elements.
This one sets up
a single element
and assigns a name to it.
You can also have
a set of elements.
You're basically passing
this map down and saying,
this item is going to
be used with this name.
And then the Launched Activity
gets all that information
on the other side.
And then you start the
activity with that information,
and away it goes.
So how they work is basically
building on the Transition
capability that
we had in KitKat.
The big idea with
transitions is,
I want to know where
things are at now.
And then I want to run
Layout and figure out
where things are at afterwards.
And then I want to
start the animation,
based on where
things were and then
animate them to where they are.
It's the same idea, except
that was in a single View
Hierarchy in an activity.
But this is applied
across activities instead.
And it's applied in
the following way.
We know what's happening to the
items in the Launched Activity.
So in the Explodes
case, for a transition,
we're going to move
all the items out.
So we're going to say, OK, I
know where everything is now.
And I know where everything
is when it's animated out.
We're going to run
that animation.
And same thing for the
Launched Activity--
we know where things
are off screen.
We can animate them on
screen, all using Transitions.
And then the final element
is the Hero Element.
So once the Launched
Activity gets the information
about the elements
that you want to share,
it says, oh, I know where to
put the album on the screen.
And I know what size
I wanted it to have.
And I know what
size and position
it had where it started.
So I'm going to run a transition
that automatically animates
those changes over time as well.
ROMAIN GUY: So sometimes the
default automated transitions
are not enough for
some types of effects.
When you use one of those
automated transitions,
the framework will look at some
specific properties of Views,
like Size, Position, Alpha.
But it doesn't know
about all the properties
that you can use
in the UI Toolkit.
So here's an example.
In the list of
thumbnails, you can
see that the thumbnails
are darkened.
So I use the Color
filter on the Image Views
to darken the thumbnail.
So what I want to do is, when we
transition to the new activity,
I want to animate that color
filter from dark to clear.
And because the Automated
Transition system does not
know how to do that, we need to
synchronize with that system,
to run the Normal
View animations when
the transition is done.
This is actually
fairly easy to do.
So to run an animation
after a transition,
you can just get the
entire transition
from your onCreate
method in your activity.
You can add the listener.
And we just listen
for onTransitionEnd.
So at the end of the
transition, I just
run my custom animations.
So in this case, I just
do the color filter
that I'm not
showing in the code,
because it's a little
more complicated.
I also fade in a
couple of buttons.
It's also important to
remove the listener,
when you're done using it.
You also want-- if we go back
to the video, you can see,
that when we go back to
the list of thumbnails,
we will want to-- if the video
plays-- OK, when we go back
to the list of thumbnails, we
want to redarken the image.
And of course, it's
not in the video.
Sorry about that.
So you want to be
able to run custom
animations before
the transition.
And an easy way to do this
is to override onBackPressed.
You run your normal
View Animations.
You listen for the end
of those animations.
And at the end, you just call
this finishAfterTransition
method.
You used to call Finish.
But if you call
finishAfterTransition,
we're going to run
the transitions
and then finish the activity.
Just be careful if you
implement those techniques.
The code is a little
bit more complicated,
if you want to deal with the
screen rotation correctly,
because if you rely on
those [? listeners, ?]
when you rotate the screen,
there won't be a transition.
And so your
animations won't run.
So it's important
to set something
in your bundle and
your safe state
and take a different
action based on that.
I mentioned animating
a color filter.
That's a technique we've shown
in presentations in the past.
It was a little painful
before, because on every frame,
you would have to create
a new color filter
instance to create
your animation.
That was generating garbage.
That was causing
[? DC ?] pauses.
So sometimes you would get
a stutter in the animation,
just because of the extra
garbage that was generated.
So as of the L Preview, you
can animate color filters,
without recreating
on every frame.
There's a new setColor method.
So here, we use an
Object Animator,
and we animate the color
property of the filter
directly.
The only trick here is that
a color filter knows nothing
about the view it's
associated with.
So just changing the
properties of the color filter
will not change what's
drawn on screen.
You need to trigger
a redraw of the View
that uses the color filter.
So an easy way to do
that, you can see here,
is to add an UpdateListener.
And on every frame, you
set the color filter again,
on the Drawable of the View
that you want to animate.
And then everything
will redraw properly.
CHET HAASE: One of the new
elements in the Preview Release
is reliance on and
more flexibility
with colors in general.
The assets that we have by
default are all gray scale.
And this is done on purpose, so
it's easier to then tint those,
as required by your application
or by different states
of your application or by
different activities within it.
So it's easier to brand
your application the way
that you want and also
to produce less assets.
So previously, if you wanted
to colorize your application,
you could certainly do
that, by creating images
with that color.
What we'd like you to do
instead is actually use
these neutral colors
and then tint them
as appropriate, to whatever
that situation is--
so much easier, much more
powerful, much more flexible.
And one of the elements that's
going to make that easier
is a new utility in the
support library, which
is the Palate utility, which
allows you to then go out.
There's another reliance
on images as well.
You've seen a lot of images in
a lot of the material design
content so far.
Wouldn't it be nice
if you could actually
figure out color information
about those images
and then use that information
to then colorized your UI,
as we saw in
Romain's demo so far?
So actually, I already
explained this.
So I'm going to just
go on to your stuff.
It's more interesting.
ROMAIN GUY: So first,
I will show you
how to change the colors
of the Static Theme.
So that was the first activity
in the demo I showed you.
So it uses pink for the
Action Bar, the Status Bar,
and the Nav Bar.
So it was also using
purple for the ripples.
And this is how it's done.
So you create a new theme.
You inherit from Theme.Material
or Theme.Material.Light.
And there are five colors.
You can override.
You see them here.
We have colorPrimary,
colorPrimaryDark,
colorBackground, colorAccent,
and colorControlHighlight.
And the system will, by
default, use those properties
to colorize the Theme.
So I colorized the
different values,
based on the actual RGB values.
You can see, for
instance, the colorAccent
and colorControlHighlights
are purple.
And that's where the
purple and the ripples
were coming from, so
entirely from the Theme.
You can see next that I've
also colorized the Navigation
Bar, the Nav Bar at the
bottom, and the Status Bar.
So I just use references to
reuse the primary dark color
from my Theme.
And I've also changed
the background color
to one of the colors
from my Theme.
So it's very easy,
very simple to do
and certainly beats creating
dozens or hundreds of assets,
just to change the
default color to green.
Now, to generate those
different secondary activities,
that all the colors
are coming from images,
things are a little
bit more difficult.
There's a new API that Chet
mention called Palette.
It comes with the
new support library.
So the draw file is
android-support-v7-palette.
And what it does is,
you give it a Bitmap.
And it will generate a series
of color from that Bitmap.
So by default, it will
try to generate 16 colors.
You can specify how
many colors you want.
It will also try to give
you six Named Colors.
And you'll see what I
mean by Named Colors.
You just have to be careful,
because those Named Colors can
be null.
So it you pass the
Palette API an image
that only contains
blue, it won't
be able to generate
those six colors for you.
So you might have to
use fall-back colors
in your application.
So this is an example of
the output of Palette.
So given that image on the left,
you can see the Named Colors.
So they are called Dark muted,
Dark vibrant, Muted, Vibrant,
Light muted, and Light vibrant.
And on the right, you
can see the full palette.
So I think it generates
something like-- I don't know.
Do the math-- 15 colors or
something, from that image.
CHET HAASE: 14.
that's 14.
ROMAIN GUY: OK.
CHET HAASE: I've
got a Math degree.
ROMAIN GUY: That
why I was fired.
This is how to use
that Palette API.
It's super simple.
You call Palette.generate.
You give it a Bitmap.
Optionally, you could use the
number of colors you want.
There's an asynchronous
version of Palette.
So if you give it
large images, it's
going to take a
fair amount of time
to generate the
Palette, because it
has to look at all the
pixels in the image.
So there's a
call-back system, so
that you can do something
else while you're
waiting for the
Palette to come back.
And this is just
an example of how
you would apply programatically
the color to your UI.
So for instance, I change
here the background Drawable.
I use the dark muted color.
So notice, that on
the Palette, when
you get a color, you
actually get a Palette item.
You don't get a color directly.
So that object can be No.
And if it's not
No, you can getRGB,
to get the RGB
color for that item.
This is a slightly
more involved example.
So here, all my
buttons used ripples.
And the ripples
in the background
of the buttons, the colors
come from the Palette as well.
And here's how you do it.
So this is the RippleDrawable
that I was using from XML.
So a RippleDrawable is
basically a layered drawable.
So you can contain a
number of other drawables.
So here, I only have
a circle inside,
so that gives me that
nice, round background.
And don't look at the color.
The colors are here just so
that the XML can be compiled.
I override those
colors from code.
And this is how they
were overridden.
So I have a background
color and the tint color
that come from my Palette.
You can call setColor
on the RippleDrawable,
to change the color of
the ripples themselves.
But if you want to change
the color of the circle,
the actual background
of the button,
since that background is a
layer in the RippleDrawable,
you first have to
call getDrawable0,
because I only have
one item on that list.
And then I can set my tint
color on that second Drawable.
Reveal-- you've seen
that animation earlier.
We're going to show it again.
So this is a new
animation that you're
going to probably see
in a lot of applications
that implement the
Material Theme.
It's just a circular
shape animation
that's used to reveal
any kind of content.
So in L, it's super easy.
You just call
ViewAnimationUtils.createCircularReveal.
And if you want to animate
that, in prior releases,
there are techniques.
So it's mostly using textured
shapes and BitmapShader.
I wrote an article on my blog
that explains how to do it.
It's fairly easy.
But that means the View
itself cannot be dynamic.
You cannot change the content of
the View during the animation.
So this is what the
Circular Reveal looks like.
When we press the Reveal
button in the bottom right,
we just reveal MapView.
So this is a fully dynamic
MapView that's not an image.
It's the actual MapView running
open GIS and can be tilted
and 3D rotated and moved.
So the good news about
the implementation
in L for Circular Reveal
is because the framework
is aware of these animations.
It's using a new implementation
that's Shader-based.
So it's much more
efficient, compared
to the way you could do
it in previous releases.
So Chet mentioned that's,
again, in a previous session.
So you could use the
stencil buffer from the GPU.
If you clipped with a path
that's extremely expensive,
you shouldn't do it.
It's also using more memory.
It was not anti-aliased.
The new solution is I
still a little bit slower,
than from not using a clipper
or from not using a Circular
Reveal.
But it's fairly efficient.
And it doesn't
use memory at all.
Just know that there's a slight
limitation in the L Preview.
The Circular Reveal is not
anti-aliased at the moment.
And it should be fixed
for the final release.
This is what the
code looks like.
So we call createCircularReveal
to reveal our MapView.
And you have to pass
four parameters--
the center of the origin
of the Reveal of the circle
animation, the Start Radius,
and the Final Radius.
So here, it's pretty easy
to do, because my button
was sitting on top
of the MapView.
So I can just get the
coordinates of the button
and use that as the
center of the reveal.
If the view from which the
reveal is originating from
is not the child of the
view you're revealing,
you might have to
do a bit of math
to convert the
coordinate systems.
But it's fairly simple.
And similarly, when you
want to hide the MapView,
you just swipe the radius.
So you go from the
full circle down to 0.
And it's going to do
the animation correctly.
And we have five minutes.
So we're going to
take questions,
instead of finishing
the presentation.
So again, that has nothing
to do with an actual design.
This is just a cool
effect that you
can implement all the
way back to API Level 1.
So this is what it looks like.
I wrote a full article online,
using a different demo.
So if you want to know
how to do that kind
of a cool visual effects,
you can go read it.
And we're going to switch
to Q&A. Blah, blah, Q&A.
CHET HAASE: Q&A, and that's it.
ROMAIN GUY: If you
have a question,
please walk to the mics.
No questions.
CHET HAASE: No running.
ROMAIN GUY: Man, we
are so good that they
understand everything.
CHET HAASE: All right.
Yeah, it's all straight
forward, very easy, great.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Memory-- how
does it deal with memory?
I mean, dealing
with images, we're
already running into memory
constraints all over the place.
CHET HAASE: Which
element are you
talking about in particular?
AUDIENCE: All these animations
and so on-- I mean, shadows.
CHET HAASE: Shadows, so the
stuff that we're showing
doesn't really put any
memory constraints on.
We are certainly creating a mesh
for the geometry for shadows.
But this is trivial, in terms of
the amount taken up by Bitmaps.
That's basically just
a bunch of vertices
that we're going to send down
to the GPU and then Shader
commands.
The image effect that
we're showing-- obviously,
if you're using
more images, you're
using more memory
for those images.
But the actual
animations that we're
talking about, not so much.
They're kind of data
structures, not really an issue.
In the back--
AUDIENCE: I have a
question regarding
the selectors with
the object animators.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you specify
a Start and an End value.
Is there a way you can say that
the the Start value of-- let's
say, you have Press State
and then a Normal State--
that the animation
to return to normal
can use to the current value.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
In fact, that is the way
that it's supposed to work.
There is a bug in the preview
release, where that is not
the way it actually works.
And so currently, in
the preview release,
you have to give
it a start value.
That bug should be fixed
in the final release.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Somewhat related
to that-- just as far
as overlapping
reveal transitions,
does one stop and
another take over?
Or are they able to
run at the same time?
ROMAIN GUY: So I do not
know the answer to that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ROMAIN GUY: Chet, tell us.
I'm thinking, if it's
on the same View,
there might be a conflict.
There's nothing to
stop you from running
different Reveals
on different Views.
But yeah, the same View, I'd
have to think about that.
Let us know what happens.
In the back, there's
nobody, so go.
AUDIENCE: For the
colorizing, is there
going to be a non-XML
programmatic solution for that?
ROMAIN GUY: Yes,
Chet, what about it?
CHET HAASE:
Programmatic access--
CHET HAASE: I say, yes.
CHET HAASE: To Theme
attributes-- the person
that is working on
that is nodding.
So either yes, or
he's falling asleep.
AUDIENCE: Or having a seizure.
CHET HAASE: Or it
was a slow nod.
It was not a seizure nod.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned, that when
you run Palette on large
images, that it's slow.
ROMAIN GUY: Well, it's
not that it's slow.
AUDIENCE: It's slower.
ROMAIN GUY: The larder
the image, the slower.
AUDIENCE: Is there a sweet spot?
It seems to me you
could shrink the image
and still get the same colors.
CHET HAASE: I was
thinking the same thing,
as he was saying that.
AUDIENCE: OK, if there's some
sweet spot, we can shrink it
and-- it probably
depends on the image.
ROMAIN GUY: The problem is that,
it really depends on the image.
And by default, I looked at the
source code of the Palette API.
And I don't remember it
doing any scaling whatsoever.
But that's kind of a
good thing, because that
means you can do it, if you
know the content of your images.
I mean, if they
are low frequency,
you can certainly
scale them down.
But for your high
frequency images,
you might lose some of
the important colors.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: So this questions is
about the activity transitions.
So when we're transitioning
between activities
and we're sharing a View--
the View in the destination
activity, I guess-- what happens
if it's like a heavier View,
like a MapView?
If it's not able to
initialize in the time
that the animation is
happening, is there
a way to deal with that?
CHET HAASE: There are
definitely some tricky bits
to this interaction.
So it's best to view activity
transitions as being these
bookend animations, where you
cannot get a seamless animation
from one to the other, because
we really don't know how long
the launched activity is
going to take to inflate.
If it's a really
expensive View Hierarchy,
if it's getting resources from
the network, whatever-- if it
takes three seconds to start
up, obviously, a seamless
transition is not
going to occur, right.
So you'll have to factor
that into whatever behavior
you want for your animation.
But having said that,
then you figure out
what the choreography should be.
In general, you probably
want to do something
like animate the items out and
then animate your hero elements
in the old activity to some
sort of standing pattern.
Just animate it up
and have it sit there
and wait until it can go
in the launched activity.
ROMAIN GUY: We have time for
one last question in the back.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering.
Since we're going to have a
first-class support for path
animation, is there going
to be any kind of support
for decoding SVGs or
similar vector formats?
CHET HAASE: Let's
be really clear.
His path animation
demo was not part
of what we were
trying to do today.
So I'm not sure where
you got the message from.
But that was basically a way
to animate paths using Android.
That wasn't like first-class
support in L APIs or anything.
So if you've go to
his blog, you can
see how he's doing that on
current releases of Android.
ROMAIN GUY: I used the
[INAUDIBLE] library
to load the SVG files.
CHET HAASE: Yeah,
so you can certainly
consume SVG and do
stuff with it already.
We have the very full
and robust path API.
All of that stuff is
usable, and that's
what he was using in his demo.
ROMAIN GUY: And we're done.
Thank you very much.
CHET HAASE: All
right, thank you.